so this is my tag response to Jamie
males's video on five pieces of sage
wisdom that he wished he'd been told
before he started uni now he started
with that premise but he actually made
it quite General he made it you know if
you're starting a new phase in your life
whereas I'm going to take this very
literally I'm going to give you five
pieces of advice that I wished I've been
told before I started uni so if you're a
fresher this year please please listen
to some of this I'd arguably if you're
starting your another year at Uni then
maybe you need to hear this as well tip
number one do things be brave be a doer
now I don't just mean this in the sense
of try things which you haven't tried
before and to go outside your comfort
zone which you absolutely should do I
more mean this in the case of don't be
the person that goes to University and
says I am just going to work the whole
time
because it's it's it's a very difficult
thing to do but it is so important to
actually do something outside of your
working time I went to Oxford and I said
to myself I'm not going to have time for
doing music or sport or anything because
I'm just going to work the whole time
time I want to do really well and I
regret that decision every day I really
wish that I'd just been a little bit
braver and said yeah I'm going to take 4
hours a week and I'm going to go to the
gym and I'm going to go and play music
but that initial step that initial
taking time out of your working day is
such a difficult step because you think
oh I'm taking time out my day that means
I'm going to have less time to work so
I'm not going to get as much work done
and you're right on the first count yes
you are going to have less time to work
but by taking the time out of your day
to do other things you're going to make
the time that you do work in so much
more effective because you have to say
to yourself oh I've got 6 hours and then
I have to be somewhere else tonight so
let's get this work done the work hasn't
got an opportunity to expand to fill the
time so go out there do things and and
just be brave go for it Point number two
connected with that plan your time now I
talk about this in my have to study
effectively video using a diary and
everything basically if you don't manage
your time you're making it so much more
difficult for yourself use a diary
whether that's an electronic one or a
paper one and plan ahead you know even
if it's just a couple of weeks know when
things are due in know when other events
are happening so that you save yourself
stress in the long run it actually took
me a while to figure this out so this
might sound obvious but yeah please do
it Point number three and arguably the
most important point of all if you are
struggling be honest about it going to
University is a massive change in your
life and a lot of people do struggle and
they can struggle for various reasons
when I went to UNI I struggled because I
wasn't used to the fact that I didn't do
any extracurricular activities and I was
really unhappy for a while in Oxford
because I just I wasn't honest with
myself I wasn't honest about the fact
that I I was unhappy and I to try to
hide it and I also wasn't honest with
the fact that sometimes I struggled with
the work and I never tried to get help
and I really regret both of those cases
I really regret never asking for help
now if you're going to unu that's
probably because you're motivated and
you're good at what you do and sometimes
it can be difficult for Motivated people
to admit that they're struggling but
it's so important that you do whether
you're struggling with the work at Uni
or with the social life or just you know
feeling down from being away from home
there are people at your uni who are
paid to take care of students who are in
a position like you they want to hear
about you the worst thing that
University welfare team can have is to
not have any students approach them
because these problems always exist
you know people get these all the time
every year students will struggle with
adapting to
UNI and you can either be honest about
it and try and get help and make the
situation better or you can bury any
discomfort and that doesn't help anyone
so be honest if you're struggling get
help Point number four try your best
this might again sound a little bit
obvious but I've known quite a few
people who have gone to University and
then just sort of given up on their
course slightly and they don't seem to
have any motivation for it anymore but
you've gone to University because you
like this subject right you've gone to
UNI because you want to study it so why
would you not want to try your best at
the thing that you really like yes there
are other things to do there's you know
like I say you you you need to go out
there and do other things and there's
socializing to do and there's growing up
to do but why would you not try your
best at your subject but you still see
people do it you still see people who
frankly don't give a crap about their
subject don't be one of those people
you're there for a reason you are there
fundamentally to get a degree and you
can have some fun along the way you can
do other things and you can develop as a
person but the reason you're there is to
get a degree and even though it can be
difficult to remember that at all times
try and keep it at least in the back of
your mind try actually put effort in
because you'd be surprised at how many
people need to be reminded of that
lastly Point number five visit your
friends because if you're like me you're
going to have plenty of friends who you
grew up with and you've known for years
and they're suddenly all dispersed and
they're going to lots of different
universities and more likely than not
you're probably not going to have anyone
at your uni that you know from home
maybe you have one or two one maybe two
people but you're going to have loads of
friends all across the country and it's
a great opportunity to go and travel and
to see parts of the country you might
not have seen before I went and visited
friends at other universities that i'
never been to the city before and it was
great because if you're anything like me
you like going new places you know it's
it's it's seeing somewhere new even and
you have reason to go there and more
likely than not you're going to have
somewhere cheap to stay so make use of
your friendship Network your friendship
network is now more interesting arguably
than ever before because it's so
dispersed because it's everywhere so go
and don't let the friendships that youve
spent years crafting go to waste because
you're friends with these people for a
reason you like them you're probably
quite a lot like them don't squander the
friendships which you've made and just
stay in your union go out there and see
your friends in other cities you'll have
a great time trust me
so those are my five quick tips for
anybody who's heading off to freshers
this tag is probably a little bit late
now because I was a bit late in getting
the video ready sorry Jamie but if any
other people who are currently
University have any advice they'd like
to give to freshes then please make a
video and post it in the comments of
this video I'd be interested to see what
you guys think is the best advice to
give this is my take and I'm sure that
it's probably wrong but as with most
things in my life that doesn't stop me
from trying so thank you Jamie for
giving me the opportunity to do this
video I think it's a very important tag
to do and um for those of you who are
subscribed to my channel you'll be
seeing me in a couple of days because I
will be doing my Draw My Life video so
see you then